we shouldn't focus on grammar in our
language learning the brain is very good
at creating patterns at recognizing
patterns so we don't need specific
grammar instruction or we don't need
very much of it in any case so that's
Point number one point number two is
focusing on grammar takes too much time
away from more useful activities we
should be spending our time massively
listening and reading and eventually
speaking the third thing is that
inevitably grammar instruction is
connected with tests it's creating a lot
of tension introducing the sense of
failure the fourth thing is that it
introduces what kraftson calls the
effective filter every time you go to
speak you got to try to think is this
correct or is that correct have the
confidence that with enough listening
and reading you will gradually develop
better and better habits the next reason
why I'm not a big fan of grammar
instruction is inevitably grammar
instruction focuses on a limited range
of
content